grexit has begun about nine months ago
UK voters chose to withdraw from the
European Union in the midst of
controversy and really pretty
compartmentalized voting England voting
to leave Scotland voting to stay we
talked about the divisions when the boat
took place the final popular vote tally
was roughly 52 to 48 in favor of leaving
the European Union and now officially
the EU has received a letter from the UK
formally triggering the beginning of
brexit which is two years of discussion
so we're still not exactly ready to
finalize the deal this is called article
50 it's the mechanism which exists for
countries to separate from the European
Union the British Prime Minister Theresa
May announced that this is a historic
moment from which there can be no
turning back it's not clear that that's
true legal experts are not completely a
unanimous about whether this is
reversible or not once you start article
50 proceedings but it doesn't matter
right now we've got the two years and a
lot needs to be figured out immigration
rules labour rules trade terms financial
regulations money among many other
things has the UK unified behind the
decision to brexit since the nearly
fifty fifty voting split nine months ago
in other words nine months ago it was
only 52 to 48 in favor of leaving have
they coalesced around their decision the
answer is absolutely not recent polling
suggests the UK is still split about
50-50 on whether to leave or stay and
some other bits and pieces here about
what we believe to be true although a
lot of this is really still in flux
number one there will reportedly be no
return to a hard border between Ireland
and Northern Ireland Theresa May the
Prime Minister trying to quell the
rumors about that that started over the
last few days Britain will leave the
jurisdiction of the European Court of
Justice when it leaves the EU that's
sort of relevant from a legal
perspective a judicial perspective
Britain is seeking a quote bold and
ambitious free-trade deal with the
European Union
and Scotland will likely have another
independence referendum you'll remember
that years ago Scotland had a referendum
about whether to leave the UK and
ultimately Scotland decided to stay as
part of the UK also during the brexit
vote Scotland voted to stay in the
European Union so now Scotland is going
to have another independence referendum
with the idea of course of separating
from the UK and remaining as an EU
member nation we don't know what's going
to happen with that but very interesting
very interesting also how the United
Kingdom deciding to fracture away from
the European Union yeah could result in
their own country fracturing into pieces
yes I especially because as you said
Scotland voted to stay with the UK
44-percent to fifty-five percent but
because the overwhelmingly wanted to
stay with the EU that could change by
the time they redo the referendum
absolutely and we also talked about
Gibraltar Gibraltar which is in terms of
proximity right next to Spain Gibraltar
also but politically part of the UK
Gibraltar voted to stay as part of the
EU and interestingly you know there's a
there's a sort of internal ongoing
conflict between Gibraltar and Spain and
I think it was the Spanish Foreign
Minister or Spanish Spanish elected
official who said hey we would love to
help to brawl Thursday as part of the EU
that they'll just have to become part of
Spain which started a whole other
similar conversation to the Scottish
conversation interesting yeah I've been
to Gibraltar and it's of course a small
Peninsula off the coast of Spain or it's
connected to the country Yale but they
have a very their their identity is both
Spanish and English in a sense and so
you could see with combining those two
things how they would want to stay with
the European Union yeah so a lot of
these things are still going to be
worked out the broader question here and
we're going to have two years to talk
about this right is can the UK pull off
sort of what we could describe as a
Switzerland situation which is sort of
conceptually trying to get the benefits
of EU partnership through treaties and
trade deals without some of the aspects
of EU membership that could be
considered more burdensome we're going
to have much time to
talk about this is going to be an
interesting couple of years